[Música]
é preciso aqui num saque também do meu
bloco pois esta apresentação não só
estar à altura dos imac com papel seguem
tendo aí sim então ao a através da
apresentação complexa eu vou falar uma
coisa bastante simples que bonecos fazer
design e começo por aqui que é imagine
um mundo de imagens
imagine um mundo onde houve imagens
aliás nem sequer estas imagens seriam
possíveis de deus mostrar e há uma razão
para isso é que nós somos nós seres
humanos somos naturalmente visuais nós
pensamos nós nascemos com esta atividade
de serviço de pensar visualmente e e
desenhar e nós falamos do futuro e
tecnologia e de desenhar é a tecnologia
mais antiga nós nós temos fazemos está
32 mil anos e é só um
vamos mostrar um número como estudar a
evolução de 2009 que nós desde o início
fazemos isso nós como crianças este é o
primeiro é a primeira forma que nós
utilizamos para aprender e para mim e
para mim e para expulsar nos esforçamos
e à medida que vamos crescendo estão
provoca na minha opinião mas à medida
que nós vamos crescendo é vamos deixando
ver vamos deixando de utilizar esta
capacidade e avaliações preciosos todos
nós sabemos isso de uma forma ou de
outra que ou não somos demasiado ou
dizem nos que não somos suficientemente
bons
ao julgamento das tentativas que
desenvolvemos com o tempo e me levava a
desenhar e é isso que eu tenho
descoberto desenhar m é simplificar essa
complexidade e engenharia na realidade
na minha opinião várias coisas e e hoje
estava nos dizer como é que desenhar
para mim não tem ajudado a compreender
melhor o mundo
os outros e no fundo a minha própria
vida
deixem começar pelo início é sempre
comprar aquilo que explodiu no início
que imaginem um mundo sem imagens
totalmente e agora imaginem como eu é
90% e informação cri havel e as 90 por
cento da informação anual foi criada nos
últimos três anos sendo que 90% dessa
informação é visual mas por via
consumimos uma média de duas mil e 500 a
4 mil imagens por dia o que significa 98
mil imagens por mês
isso é bastante difícil processar aliás
o próprio o próprio exercício imaginamos
o mundo
são imagens é altamente complexo nós
estamos rodeados de informação visual
por todo lado e eu estava com um visual
e os cada vez mais comprar online compra
online é pessoal é pagaram no ano e
visual tudo que fazemos é visual e esse
é o nosso novo normal normal após
estamos habituados e no bis foi tão no
ponto de vista empresarial cada vez mais
esta regra na medida em que cada vez
mais empresas utilizam métodos em todos
os dias como está enfim quem o vídeo
'thinking started alguns cremes e são
tudo técnicas altamente visuais que se
lhe tão esta colaboração eficiente e que
o trabalho de alguma forma corra mais
rapidamente e melhor e relativamente ao
futuro
se alguma coisa que nós sabemos sobre o
futuro já sofremos algumas coisas já
aprendemos algumas coisas novas sobre o
futuro mas uma coisa que nós sabemos é
que é incerto e
a única certeza que temos é esta caixa
de ferramentas é que temos aqui o jogo é
porque ninguém falou falou de uma série
delas e o pensamento visual
na minha opinião e é uma na minha
opinião porque pra mim diz muito mas é
bastante importantes e e é sobre isso
que eu gostaria de falar os tal como
escrever em forma de registar o nosso
pensamento global desenhar e forma de
estar no nosso pensamento visual
desenhar bem não é desenhar bonito que
faz uma grande diferença imagens criando
as vossas cabeças com esta pergunta qual
aliás esta é a conclusão que é uma coisa
que o outro rendimento que eu não sei
desenhar
eu não sei desenhar e eu acho que se eu
não sei desenhar tem a ver precisamente
com isso que eu não sei desenhar bem
são tantas as referências visuais que
nós temos com nós imaginamos uma casa
pensamos numa casa complexa que já vi
tantas vezes mas é provável que uma casa
na mesma um caminho mais complexa e
outro queridinho - e ea facto esqui que
interessa nesse caso e nós fazemos isso
muitas vezes nós tínhamos muitas vezes e
nos apercebemos disso quando nós
estipulamos para explicar aos outros que
estamos a dizer estamos a desenhar
quando nós vemos como é que as peças não
possam se encaixam já estamos a desenhar
se nós olhamos com o problema e
percebemos aquilo que está em falta já
estamos a desenhar e sobretudo se
pegarmos no merca do preto o colocamos
no papel e chegamos à mão
nós já estamos a desenhar e aproveitando
o embalo
eu gostaria de falar sobre a importância
do alfabeto visual que de alguma forma
nos vai permitir dispensar-nos este é um
processo muito curtinho mas mas pode ser
pode ser uma boa ferramenta quanto mais
não seja para ficar é marina
nós realmente nosso alfabeto visual
começa com um triângulo com um círculo
comparava com uma linha curva como linha
reta e um ponto todos conseguem fazer
isto de uma forma sim em conseguir
consegue fazer isso não sei fazer um
cerco entre algumas derivações cronista
e expandir o velório ocorrerá se
transforma em retângulos não é um
retângulo mas e umas ondas
só para exemplificar a importância disto
e sensor jogar aqui no exercício que vos
mostrar duas figuras geométricas
uma delas estava uma forma visual está
desenhada e outra está em forma verbal
escrita tem um segundo para identificar
as duas figuras geométricas prontos 321
quem cria um círculo na mão e outra qual
era uma bolinha com pequenas o assunto
era um circo tamanho
isso significa que o nosso cérebro tem
duas têm formas diferentes de absorção
de informação no na informação escrita
na informação
nesse caso escrita e verbal ou escrita
nós fazemos um processo e nós ainda
avançamos linearmente e e pensamos em
partes letras palavras frases palavras
no na absorção visual nós fazemos uma
absorção sistêmica portanto todas as
partes são construção são entre
utilizadas como um todo e aproveitando
eliéser estava a falar sobre isto mas
acho que está a apresentação
e aproveitando isto vou contar os duas
histórias
estava então fui passar o fim de semana
numa montanha e na altura da estrada
tive um furo no meu pneu utilizar o
telefone para pedir um reboque mas
estava sem fio e comecei a andar pelos
trava e da altura vi uma casa e quando
eu fica obrigado para províncias quinta
outra história disse uma fatia pisa é
igualmente de santa comba trio uma fatia
pisa lei complementar a fatia de pizza
só não vendeu a fatia importante que
encomendaram uma pisa completa como o
cume toda puxa caixa no frigorífico e no
dia seguinte descobri que não tinham
roubar a caixa pisa tantã e ao mais um
fato interessante sobre o modo como
nosso cérebro neve que a informação ao
menos a processa que é uma teoria uma
teoria que ela tire fita dirigida
público de ficção dupla eo nosso cérebro
recebe a informação visual e verbal
mais uma vez oral escrita por um dos
canais diferentes e armazena essa
informação em dois recipientes em
recipientes distintos que contém uma
determinada capacidade
portanto nós tivemos a informação visual
e verbal
estamos a dar documento mais informação
e sobretudo uma vantagem porque elas
cruzam os portanto escrever meu escrever
pisa
vocês nunca mais verão estes dois tiros
podem ser qualquer coisa de outra forma
isso é o que chama é de que em três
coisas pelo menos dia isso é o que chama
é comunicação eficiente quando nós
conseguimos reunir oral e escrito e
visual
desta forma nós conseguimos realmente
significar é a mensagem e votar aquilo
que vem mais atrás
a que propósito do texto
no nosso curso rápido
outro argumento para além do nosso
alfabeto visual é o texto todos nós
conseguimos fazer trabalhos trabalho
destaca
e essa informação escrita certas as
ligações
rio - ligação e em caixas da informação
queremos armas na vida meta
acho que às vezes também podem ser
ligações uma última e esta é a versão
3.0 podemos acrescentar não tem mais de
vida sombra e corpo
e desta forma uma história altamente
interessante com uma pisa por ganhar um
pouquinho mais de vida e temos assim o
caso da pizza desaparecida
para que todos os estudos momentos aqui
contidos foram os momentos do alfabeto
visual dos dois no início linhas formas
geométricas e cintos mas é começar e
este é o conselho que dou uma forma
bastante humilde e nulo para para
começarem simplesmente comecem por vocês
mas lembrando histórias é uma coisa que
nas histórias que é correto que todos
nós conseguimos identificar como sendo
quase o elo o goiás o fio condutor que é
um personagem e não é a personagem mais
importante das nossas vidas dos nossos
próprios e começa em e problemas do
futuro neste futuro incerto e depende
apenas de si só nós e façam perguntas
façam as faça uma pergunta qual teria de
haver uma resposta por exemplo eu vou
rasgar as folhas porque não teve efeito
a cova certa que seguir isso que
acontece
só que vamos viajar depois deste curso
feito
será que vamos continuar a estudar para
construir essas competências acadêmicas
será que vamos seguir uma carreira que
começamos já será que vamos encontrar um
emprego pra ganhar algum dinheiro e
alguma experiência de sylvester serve
isto para dizer que a informação que nós
temos aqui dentro
se nós quisermos ficar fora não é que o
que é invisível as tornamos street e véu
quando volta para dentro vai muito mais
qualificado
é por isso que eu acredito que desenhar
é pensar entre outras coisas e no início
isso porque
e desenhar para mim mesmo é é o tenha
ajudado a ver melhor o mundo a
compreender melhor o mundo os outros e
no fundo a mim é minha vida
compreendo melhor o mundo porque acabei
por por desembocar numa profissão ou
pelo menos parte dela em que nem que tem
que trabalhar e estar visualmente uma
série de assuntos
as 1 200 dos quais pouco conheço mas dá
uma maneira mostram muito sobre um mundo
desconhecido e sobretudo os outros e
está altamente correlacionado monstro
falso dos outros mas são software fiz
minhas e pra dizer neste processo nesse
processo em contexto a desenhar
eu estou visto escutar ativamente é uma
coisa que eu tenho aprendido a fazer com
o tempo porque tem essa responsabilidade
de transportar e visual algo que algo
que muitas vezes em extrato e é minha
vida e agora partilhar convosco que
nunca partir desta forma eu tenho eu
tenho estes estímulos kings que já já
usava há cerca de 15 anos e são mais o
meu bem mais mais precioso que deus
existe uma série de coisas
estas são as flechas já as versões mais
acabadas
mas muitas vezes têm este aspecto que é
tudo muito confuso e tem coagem existem
riscos e fazer
são fatos etc mas sobretudo quando eu
olho essa é a grande vantagem pra mim
que quando eu olho para trás e óleo para
um uisquinho feito ou por uma página
feita em 2002 é e consigo perceber que
quando estava naquele momento que eu não
sabia naquele momento e que depois mais
tarde descobri e conseguir perceber e
ficou estável ficou ali ficou registado
ou seja dá uma noção da mansão
isso não é coisa que eu o que eu mostro
como dizia nas primeiras vezes que estou
a mostrar isso o valor global que dá uma
noção da medição de percurso
eu tenho filho tem três anos
eu não vivo com eu eu
nós vivemos mas separados por 300
quilômetros
esta situação não houve isso chegar e é
possivelmente das situações mais
difíceis que alguma vez tive que ir
cuidar e ensinar pra mim tem tem esta
tem essa vantagem que poderá
exteriorizar é que o copom vai estar
dentro quando é difícil suportar mais a
desenhar para mim também têm esta é esta
violência e quando nós nos falamos todos
os dias pois time e criamos histórias
por faz time que pois mais tarde
concluímos quando estamos juntos tanto
portanto obrigado a falar outra vez e
era que gostaria de concluir que quando
nós desenhamos nós queríamos ligações
são ligações que não são úteis para nós
isso brigamos com os outros seja
profissionalmente seja pessoalmente eu
acho que esta é realmente a grande
vantagem da do do ato de desenhar vai se
aposentar todos temos e um e sobretudo é
é significativo quando desenhamos o que
não vemos porque aquilo que vemos a
variadíssimas formas de hoje está
portanto desenhar o que não se vê é
talvez aquela que eu tenho que eu
descobri ser a maior vantagem de
desenhar
agora sim obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]